so how can you reconcile halting the
lifting of restrictions with today's
news of no
covert deaths well our science
correspondent thomas moore is with me
now thomas
so let's start with that good news no
new deaths have been reported
in the last 24 hours now there is often
a delay
in reporting following a weekend or bank
holiday but even still
it's a significant moment in the
pandemic which has claimed more than 127
000 lives
so how can it be that there are zero
deaths at the same time
some scientists are warning that the
third wave has already started
well these are cases the death figures
reflect
the infection rate a month ago back then
there were 2
000 a day now there are more than 3 000
a day a result of lockdown being lifted
and the indian variant
so will the rise in cases mean a rise in
death
well it depends on the vaccine rollout
25
million adults have now had both doses
giving good though not perfect
protection
but it still means a quarter of adults
have yet to have any dose
and half still do a second they could
spread the virus
so some people are likely to still need
hospital treatment just as the nhs
is under rising pressure for other
reasons in scotland where the easing of
restrictions has been poured
weekly a and e in tendencies are nearing
pre-pandemic levels with more than
800 last month that's just below where
they were
in march 2020 at a time when we were
going into the first lockdown
in a bid to protect the nhs so while
there is still hope in the latest
figures we're not
in the clear yet many scientists argued
that delaying the lifting of the last of
the lockdown restrictions on june the
21st
would allow more people to be protected
by the vaccine rollout
but against that any delay would put
back
the economic recovery the balance
between the two
is a political decision